[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend ihnen wenn die Haushaltsexperten
der Politik von
Handlungsbedarf reden dann beschreibt
das ein Problem dass man als Bürger
kennt es fehlt noch Geld und man weiß
nicht woher es kommen soll auch wir alle
haben ja privat immer mal wieder
Handlungsbedarf aber beim Bundeshaushalt
geht es natürlich um ganz andere Summen
um große Fragen um Weichenstellung für
Jahrzehnte der neue Haushaltsentwurf hat
noch Handlungsbedarf aber er ist heute
zumindest schon mal vom Kabinett
beschlossen worden wenn man sich die
monatelangen internen Reibereien darum
anguckt dann war das ja zwischenzeitlich
fast schon nicht mehr zu erwarten ich
spreche gleich mit dem Finanzminister
erst Britta Buchholz und die
445,7 Milliarden schweren Details
er will der sein der wieder spart der
Finanzminister moniert Ausgaben Wünsche
und allenfallsreichtum bei seinen
Kabinettskollegen es sei keine Zeit für
neue Schulden oder neue Steuern ein
neues Denken müssen her
dieser Haushalt hier ist also insofern
nur der Beginn einer Trendumkehr nach
Jahren der expansiven Finanzpolitik er
ist nicht bereits die erfolgte
Trendwende das wird eine Daueraufgabe in
den nächsten Jahren bleiben eine
Daueraufgabe sie alle müssen sparen nach
dem Krisenjahr 2021 sollen nun die
Ausgaben nach unten gedrückt werden eine
geringere Neuverschuldung 16,6
Milliarden um gerade so die
Schuldenbremse wieder einzuhalten mehr
ausgeben darf nur einer der
Verteidigungsminister außerdem hat er
das Schulden finanzierte Bundeswehr
Sondervermögen aber eine Trendumkehr
sehen nicht alle der Finanzminister der
so viel Schulden gemacht hat in
Deutschland bisher wie keiner seiner
Vorgänger und zwar mit Abstand überragt
er die alle weil er nämlich nicht nur im
normalen Haushalt im letzten Jahr in
diesem Jahr so viele Schulden aufnimmt
sondern vor allen Dingen auch in den
nebenhaushalten doch damit soll Schluss
sein besonders trifft ist das
Gesundheitsministerium eine konkrete
Sparmaßnahme eine Milliarde an
Zuschüssen zur Pflegeversicherung sollen
wegfallen höchstwahrscheinlich steigen
deshalb auch bald die Beitragssätze für
alle Kritik
das wichtigste finde ich dass die
Bundesregierung wirklich darauf achtet
dass nicht an Sozialleistungen gekürzt
wird das ist im Moment echtes falsche
Signal wenn die Menschen zu wenig Geld
haben und wenn eben wirklich zum
Beispiel auch für die häusliche Pflege
noch dringend was getan werden muss dann
darf eine Streichung von einer Milliarde
für die Pflege nicht dazu führen dass
die Leistung gekürzt werden ja und stößt
auf das jetzt gespart wird und gerade
das zu Lasten der Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer aber auch der sozial
Schwachen geht besonders umstritten
bleibt der Etat der Familienministerin
bei der Kindergrundsicherung wie sie
mehr Geld beim Elterngeld sparen viele
finden das ein katastrophales Signal
gegen Kinder ihre Petition gegen die
elterngeldstreichung haben fast 400.000
Menschen unterschrieben
dass wir Kinderarmut in diesem Land
haben und zwar zu Hauf ist ein
Armutszeugnis für die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt das hat aber
jetzt nichts mit dieser Petition zu tun
dass wir sagen okay weil es eine
Kindergrundsicherung braucht können wir
jetzt ja Elterngeld für Menschen die
hier Steuern zahlen hart arbeiten gut
ausgebildet sind einfach senken
umstritten ist die Idee auch in der
Ampel Briefe werden publik in denen das
Finanzministerium zum Sparen aufgerufen
hat aber eben nicht zur
elterngeldstreichung ein neuer Zankapfel
denn klar gemacht dass wir das für keine
gute Idee halten die Einkommen weiter zu
deckeln wie Frau Paust das
offensichtlich jetzt vorgeschlagen hat
wir werden das sicherlich in der Form
nicht mittragen können als fdpression
der FDP Finanzminister muss als nächstes
seinen Vorschlag im Bundestag
verteidigen klar ist aber jetzt schon in
dem Entwurf Licht einiges an Sprengkraft
Christian Lindner ist der zuständige
Bundesfinanzminister Helena guten Abend
hallo einen schönen guten Abend sie
sagen der Haushaltsentwurf ist eine
Rückkehr zur Normalität heißt denn das
zur Normalität gehören jetzt immer auch
heftiger Auseinandersetzungen innerhalb
der Regierung ums Geld
ich fürchte dass wir vor einer für unser
Land insgesamt schwierigen Zeit stehen
wir haben große
Bedarfe zu investieren etwa in die
Digitalisierung in den Klimaschutz wir
müssen mehr tun für den Bereich von
Bildung Innovation in unsere
Wirtschaftskraft zugleich haben wir hohe
Zinsen das bedeutet die Mittel sind
knapp und dann muss sehr genau
miteinander gesprochen werden wo die
knappen Mittel eingesetzt werden sehr
genau miteinander gesprochen jetzt gab
es ja in der Vergangenheit eine ganze
Menge Streit hat sich auch alles sehr
sehr lange hingezogen vielleicht gucken
wir mal kurz auf ein zwei Details die
Kinder Grundsicherung ist ja gerade
aktuell in der Diskussion die bekommt
jetzt einen Bruchteil dessen was die
Ministerin dafür will um Kinderarmut
einzudämmen eigentlich war das mal ein
gemeinsames Projekt der Ampel das
Elterngeld wird für gut Verdiener
gestrichen überall sieht die
Familienministerin Sie Herr Lindner als
den Schuldigen können sie damit gut
leben
nein wir haben ja die Mittel auch für
den Bereich von Familien und von Bildung
verstärkt man kann die Geschichte auch
anders erzählen wir schaffen ein
startchancenprogramm 4.000 Schulen
sollen unterstützt werden gerade dort wo
es besondere soziale Aufgaben gibt etwa
mit einer besseren Ausstattung beim
Elterngeld ist das letzte Wort noch
nicht gesprochen die Familienministerin
selbst hat ja bedenken bei der von ihr
jetzt konkretisierten Maßnahmen selbst
sagte diese Maßnahme ist ihr vom
Finanzministerium ans Herz gelegt worden
und zwar sehr deutlich anders etwas
anders also das ein fdp-vorsitzender
Menschen mit hoher Qualifikation
Leistungsträger belastet ich glaube das
ist eher unwahrscheinlich dass das mein
Wunsch ist aber eins ist richtig wir
müssen die Ausgabensteigerung auch beim
Elterngeld gegen den Bundeshaushalt
begrenzen des Jahres die mit größte
Leistung im Haushalt des
Familienministeriums aber wie das im
Einzelnen passiert das ist in der
fachpolitischen Verantwortung
erklärt sie sagen sie wollen die
Leistung beim Elterngeld begrenzen aber
wollen irgendwie dann doch nicht als
fdp-vorsitzender wie sie gerade sagten
ans Elterngeld dran wie sollen das jetzt
beides zusammenpassen es gibt ja andere
Möglichkeiten was man tun kann es muss
ja nicht eine einkommenskappung bei
150.000 Euro sein sondern es sind ja
auch andere Möglichkeiten was man dort
tun also einfach weniger Elterngeld
übrigens könnte man auch an anderen
Stellen im Einzelplan des
Familienministeriums bei anderen
Programmen Mittel organisieren das hat
ja etwa das Wirtschaftsministerium
gemacht ich habe eine Ausgaben
Obergrenze für das
Wirtschaftsministerium vorgeben müssen
die Ausgestaltung aber da hat natürlich
immer Vorrang das was die zuständigen
fachministerinnen und Fachminister sagen
einer Tatsache sie wird kommen wir nicht
vorbei wir reden doch Siri ich verstehe
dass sie über Einzelmaßnahmen sprechen
nur mir ist der strategische Blick
entscheidend wir müssen die
Schuldenbremse einhalten wir haben hohe
Inflation und wir haben gleichzeitig
gefahren was die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung angeht wir können also die
Steuern nicht erhöhen gleichzeitig
müssen wir rekordmäßig investieren damit
dieses Land weiter Zukunft hat und das
bedeutet es müssen auch unpopuläre
Entscheidungen getroffen werden und was
sie jetzt aber gemacht haben Melinda ist
ja ganz interessant sie haben die großen
Batzen also wirklich das ganz große Geld
haben sie ihn neben Haushalte
ausgelagert das sind gigantische
schuldentöpfe muss man sagen nehmen wir
zum Beispiel den Klima und
Transformation vor der die Energiewende
abfedern anstoßen soll der ist erstmal
ausgeklammert worden dabei umfasst er an
eher allein dieser Form allein fast 40%
des gesamten regulären Haushalts ist der
klassische Haushalt dann nicht auch
irgendwie eine Mogelpackung geworden
nein im Gegenteil wir werden 2024 5
Sondervermögen abschaffen die wird es
nicht mehr geben das heißt mein Ziel ist
die zu reduzieren ja aber die großen
Sondervermögen also sonderschulden
sprich für die Bundeswehr und für Klima
und Transformation die sind ja weiter da
und die sind so gigantisch dass sie vom
vom Volumen her schon fast an die Hälfte
des gesamten Haushalts rankommen das ist
doch ein umbuchen und ein ich sage jetzt
mal vorsichtig gesagt ein kreatives
umbuchen was sie da veranstalten nein
ich buche ja äh kann ich so kreativ und
wie sie sagen wir haben erstens das
Sonderprogramm für die Bundeswehr im
Grundgesetz das ist eine im Grundgesetz
verankerte einmalige Ausnahme für die
Ertüchtigung der Bundeswehr weil wir die
Vernachlässigung sonst so schnell gar
nicht dort beseitigen könnten zum
zweiten haben wir den Klima und
transformationsform der hat eigene
Einnahmen beispielsweise aus dem
CO2-Preis und er hat eine Rücklage
dieses Sondervermögen wurde von der
Vorgängerregierung übrigens eingerichtet
aber der ist klar Herr Lindner wie er
genau aussieht wie hoch ist der denn zum
Beispiel dieser Fonds haben sie da schon
konkrete Angaben machen können heute ja
natürlich es sind etwa 170 Milliarden
Euro geplant für die ganzen nächsten
Jahre und wie im letzten Jahr und in der
Vergangenheit kommt der Wirtschaftsplan
nach dem Haushaltsentwurf auch das ist
jetzt nichts Neues und es gibt etwas
Drittes Herr Siebert es gibt den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der
wurde von der Vorgängerregierung während
der corona-pandemie eingerichtet und in
diesem Fond sind viele Kredit
Ermächtigungen die wir aber zum Glück
nicht nutzen die waren nämlich
exklusiv für die Strom und
gaspreisbremse und zum Glück haben die
Preise sich wieder reduziert so dass die
Mittel die dort zur Verfügung stehen es
waren mal 200 Milliarden Euro an
Ermächtigungen die werden sehr weit
überwiegend gar nicht ausgeschöpft und
der Zweck wird auch nicht verändert
lassen Sie uns noch ganz kurz über ein
anderes aktuelles Thema reden
Finanzminister hat ja mit allem zu tun
wie sehr tut es ihnen weh dass der Bund
jetzt 243 Millionen Euro Schadensersatz
zahlen muss wegen der verkaufsten
Pkw-Maut holen Sie sich das vom
ehemaligen Verkehrsminister andreas
Scheuer zurück
das sind Entscheidungen der
Vergangenheit gewesen die sich jetzt als
falsch herausgestellt haben auch gegen
guten Rat seinerzeit und das müssen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger jetzt politisch
bewerten was ein Verkehrsminister der
CSU der csu-vorhaben umsetzt was der am
Ende für den Steuerzahler gebracht hat
politisch bewerten und auch bezahlen
die Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
müssen das bezahlen und zugleich können
Sie das aber dann auch politisch
bewerten sagt der Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner vielen Dank für das
Gespräch ja gerne
und das Interview haben wir aus Termin
gründen um 19 Uhr aufgezeichnet die
Betreiberfirma des mautprojekts die den
Geld Segen aus Steuermitteln jetzt
bekommt hat bereits ihre
Geschäftsprognose angehoben sie erwartet
jetzt eine signifikante Verbesserung des
operativen Ergebnisses die teure und
traurige Geschichte der Pkw-Maut in
Deutschland ein Lehrstück über
politische Ambitionen und ihr Scheitern
Christian hübscher hat mehr
er ist nur der Überbringer der
schlechten Botschaft Volker Wissing
amtierender Verkehrsminister muss den
Deutschen heute zumuten was ihnen sein
Amtsvorgänger noch eingebrockt hat der
Schadensersatz für die PKW-Maut die nie
kommen sollte danach muss die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
243 Millionen Schadenersatz bezahlen das
ist eine bittere Summe das ist nahezu
eine viertel Milliarde Euro und das ist
Geld für das die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in unserem Land hart gearbeitet haben es
war der
csu-wahlkampfschlager es wurde die
größte Pleite des andreas Scheuer eine
automaut nur für Ausländer die der
Europäische Gerichtshof 2019
abschmetterte doch zu diesem Zeitpunkt
hatte der damalige Verkehrsminister die
Milliarden schweren Verträge längst
unterschrieben die verhinderten
mautbetreiber verlangten Schadensersatz
ursprünglich sogar mehr als das Doppelte
und stimmten nun einen Vergleich mit dem
Staat zu wir haben einen vernünftigen
Kompromiss gefunden wir hätten auch noch
jahrelang weiter klagen können dann
wären Zinsen aufgelaufen es ist für alle
keine schöne Entwicklung das ist hierzu
gekommen ist es war unseres Erachtens
auch überflüssig wir hätten gerne die
PKW-Maut hier in Deutschland umgesetzt
als klar wurde wie teuer das Maut
Desaster werden könnte ließ scheuer
meterweise Akten in den Bundestag
schieben auch ein Untersuchungsausschuss
zwang ihn nicht zum Rücktritt bis zum
Schluss zeigte der damalige Minister
keine rolle ich verstehe den Unmut auch
über dieses Projekt und die Entwicklung
dazu fakt ist aber
dass wir rechtens gehandelt haben
inzwischen ist er einfacher
Bundestagsabgeordneter auf Anfragen
reagiert scheuer heute nicht und aus
seiner Partei CSU findet sich bisher nur
ein einsamer Verteidiger bedauerlich
wenn der Bund jetzt hier 243 Millionen
Euro weil er Voraussicht nach zahlen
muss aber hier nur einer Partei nur der
CSU den schwarzen Peter zuzuschieben das
sollte ich schon für etwas zu einfach
aus den ampelparteien kommt Kritik für
all die Steuerverschwendung wir hätten
unsere vorstellen können dass SPD das
Geld für andere bessere Zwecke
einzusetzen das geht jetzt zu Lasten des
Haushalts des deutschen Steuerzahlers
und das muss ich die CSU jetzt auf die
Fahnen schreiben eigentlich wäre es
richtig wenn die CSU Anstand hat und
auch ein bisschen Verantwortung
übernimmt dass sie anbieten würde diese
Rechnung aus ihrem privaten
parteivvermögen zu bezahlen auf die 243
Millionen kommen nun noch Anwaltskosten
oben drauf viel Geld das im Verkehr
fehlen wird so Volker Wissing nach vier
Jahren endet damit einer der größten
politischen Flops
ja und dann eine Eilmeldung gerade eben
die die politische Planung in Berlin
durcheinander wirbeln dürfte und zwar
ganz erheblich das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die für
Freitag im Bundestag geplante
Entscheidung zum
gebäudeenergiegesetz besser bekannt als
heizungsgesetz gestoppt es folgte damit
dem Antrag des Berliner CDU-Abgeordneten
Thomas Heilmann auf Erlass einer
einstweiligen Anordnung Heilmann sah
seine Rechte als Abgeordneter verletzt
wegen der Eile im Gesetzgebungsverfahren
bei diesem Gesetz den Abgeordneten muss
jetzt also mehr Zeit gegeben werden das
wird für heftige Diskussionen sorgen im
Parlament und dort heute etwas was es im
Bundestag noch nie gegeben hatte die
Regierungsfraktionen lehnen einen
Untersuchungsausschuss ab den die
Opposition gerne wollte und der einen
speziell im Fokus gehabt hätte der für
die Regierung heute ein wichtiger Mann
ist Hanna damit beginnst du jetzt mit
den Stimmen der Ampel Fraktionen hat der
Bundestag heute einen
Untersuchungsausschuss zum Steuer
Skandal bei der Hamburger Warburg Bank
blockiert beantragt hatte ihn die Union
konkret hätte dabei auch die Rolle von
Bundeskanzler Scholz beleuchtet werden
sollen der zum Zeitpunkt der cumex
Affäre Hamburger Bürgermeister war die
ampelparteien lehnten den Antrag ab weil
der U-Ausschuss vor allem Vorgänge in
der Hamburger Verwaltung untersuchen
sollte die Union kündigte eine Klage vor
dem Bundesverfassungsgericht an
die Ukraine und Russland beschuldigen
sich gegenseitig Anschläge auf Europas
größtes Atomkraftwerk in saporicia
vorzubereiten der ukrainische Präsident
selenski hatte Moskau gestern Abend
vorgeworfen auf den Dächern mehrere
Reaktorblöcke Gegenstände zu platzieren
die Sprengstoff endeten kremmelsprecher
Peskow warnte heute hingegen vor der
Gefahr einer Sabotage durch Kiew die
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde hat
nun einen erweiterten Zugang für die
dort stationierten Beobachter gefordert
das AKW wird von Russland kontrolliert
israel hat seinen groß angelegten
Militäreinsatz im West jordanland
offiziell beendet alle Soldaten sein aus
der Stadt Jenin abgezogen worden hieß es
ist am Montag hatte der Einsatz begonnen
Ziel war laut Militär die Zerschlagung
terroristischer Infrastruktur insgesamt
wurden damals 12 Palästinenser getötet
außerdem starb ein israelischer Soldat
Janine und das angrenzende
Flüchtlingslager gelten als Hochburg
militanter Palästinenser
über den Norden Deutschlands sind heute
Sturm und Orkanböen hinweggezogen im
Emsland wurde eine Frau von einem
entwurzelten Baum erschlagen
sturmtief-poli brachte
Windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 130
km/h mit sich zuvor hatte der
Sommersturm in den Niederlanden gewütet
auch dort kam ein Mensch ums Leben am
Flughafen Schiphol wurden mehr als 300
Flüge gestrichen
Weizen Mais Reis mit diesen drei
Pflanzen decken wir Menschen den
Großteil unseres Bedarfs an pflanzlichen
Kalorien im gleichen Maße wie die
Weltbevölkerung wächst müsste also auch
deren Ertrag wachsen
gleichzeitig wächst mit dem Klimawandel
auch der Druck Landwirtschaft zu
verändern die globale Erwärmung dürfte
uns zwingen das im großen Maßstab zu tun
für viele Anbaugebiete wird es neue
Sorten geben müssen die resistenter sind
und genügsamer und das hinzubekommen
will die EU das auch gentechnisch
veränderte Futter und Lebensmittel
künftig einfacher erforscht und ohne
spezielle Kennzeichnung verkauft werden
dürfen für die einen überfälliger
Schritt für die anderen gefährlicher
Dammbruch ultra
wird sie hier gefunden die superpflanze
die dem Wind der Hitze und der Dürre
trotzt die weniger Wasser braucht und
widerstandsfähiger gegen Pilze ist
Professor Nikolaus von Viren ist so
etwas wie ein pflanzenflüsterer der
Zellbiologe versucht das genaterial von
zum Beispiel Getreidesorten so zu
optimieren dass ihnen längere Wurzeln
wachsen
gerade bei unserem Kulturpflanzen geht
es jetzt darum diese Gene zu
modifizieren dass eben die Wurzeln auch
tiefere wurzbodenschichten erreichen
können längere Wurzeln helfen gegen die
Trockenheit das weiß Bauer Erich gossen
nur zu gut der Klimawandel bedroht seine
Ernte er versucht widerstandsfähigere
Getreidesorten natürlich zu züchten aber
das dauert Jahre deshalb setzt er auf
die Wissenschaft die genomisch
veränderte Getreidesorten entwickelt
der Klimawandel sagt uns ja es geht
schneller die Entwicklung hin zu anderen
Bedingungen und deshalb haben die
Pflanzen vielleicht nicht ganz so viel
Zeit sich anzupassen und die Züchtung so
viel Zeit anzupassen
bei der neuen Methode verwenden die
Forscher eine sogenannte genschere bei
dieser Technik werden keine fremden Gene
verpflanzt sondern nur vorhandene Gene
auf der DNA ausgetauscht die z.B dafür
sorgen dass die Pflanze
widerstandsfähiger ist im
Leibniz-Institut warten Sie schon lange
auf eine Lockerung der Gesetze zur
Gentechnik denn dann können die Forscher
das Labor verlassen nur auf dem Feld
entscheidet sich ob die Pflanze dann
wirklich das gewünschte Merkmal
ausprägen kann das heißt eine erhöhte
Krankheitsresistenz zeigt oder eine
erhöhte Toleranz gegenüber zum Beispiel
Hitze oder Trockenheit die Züchtung
dieser super Pflanzen gegen den
Klimawandel ist ein Milliardengeschäft
ein umkämpfter Markt in den USA gibt es
keine Einschränkung für diese Gentechnik
auch das ist wohl ein Grund für die
EU-Kommission diese Technik zu
unterstützen sie will deshalb das
Gentechnikgesetz lockern damit diese
Pflanzen schneller angebaut werden
können ist eine solche genomisch
veränderte Pflanze ist
widerstandsfähiger gegen dörren und
benötigt weniger Pestizide um zu wachsen
kritiker bezweifeln dass diese super
Pflanzen weniger Pestizide brauchen
außerdem dass die EU-Kommission nun die
Kennzeichnung solcher genomisch
veränderter Pflanzen nicht vorschreibt
sei ein Fehler die Bürger müssen wissen
was im Essen ist und das ist ja ein
Recht der Europäischen Union das hier
keine ungeprüften Produkte auf den Markt
dürfen und genau das macht die
Kommission eigentlich ein fundamentaler
Verstoß gegen europäisches Recht
die super Pflanzen eine Antwort auf den
Klimawandel die nicht jeder für
befriedigend hält nun müssen sich damit
noch die EU Regierungschefs und dass der
EU-Parlament beschäftigen
Fragen dazu an einen agrarökonomen gegen
0.30 im heute journal Update und jetzt
hier bei uns noch mal Johanna kurz vor
dem Besuch von us-finanzministerin
Jellen in China hat die Volksrepublik
angekündigt die Ausfuhr von wichtigen
Rohstoffen für die chip-industrie
einzuschränken hintergrund ist ein
Konflikt zwischen China und dem Westen
der schon länger schwebt und Frank
Bethmann der auch uns hier in
Deutschland ganz konkret betrifft ja
weil wir auch hierzulande diese
Rohstoffe benötigen sie sind knapp und
zudem wichtig für die Herstellung von
Solarpanelen aber auch für Computerchips
jeglicher Art wie sie in der Halbleiter
Auto oder Luft und Raumfahrtindustrie
verwendet werden also da hängen Links
nicht nur US-amerikanische Interessen
dran und Peking hat nun gesagt ab dem
ersten August müssen alle Firmen für die
Ausfuhr von Gallium und
germaniumprodukten eine Lizenz
beantragen da die Volksrepublik laut
Schätzungen in den Weltmarkt bei
Germanium zu 83 Prozent und bei Gallium
sogar mit 94% beherrscht kann diese Form
der Exportkontrolle als ein sehr
scharfes Schwert gegen den Westen
verstanden werden denn im Handumdrehen
könnte ich China daraus ein Exportverbot
machen warum reagieren die Chinesen denn
jetzt mit diesem Schritt ja weil die USA
und ihre Verbündeten erst vor wenigen
Tagen selber Beschränkungen auf
Ausfuhren nach China erlassen haben
nicht die ersten Metalls einschneidenden
Sanktionen versucht der Westen zu
verhindern dass China moderne
schip-fabriken bauen kann auch um die
Volksrepublik beim Thema künstliche
Intelligenz einzubremsen nun also lässt
auch Peking die Muskeln spielen vielen
Dank für designordnung
das Schlichtungsverfahren im Tarifstreit
der Deutschen Bahn und der Gewerkschaft
EVG soll am 17 Juli beginnen und ist bis
zum 31 Juli angesetzt das gaben heute
beide Seiten bekannt als Schlichter
sollen der frühere
cdu-bundesinnenminister Thomas de
Maizière und die arbeitsrechtlerin Heide
Pfarr von der SPD vermitteln vor und
während der Schlichtung geht die
sogenannte Friedenspflicht das heißt es
darf nicht bestreicht werden und jetzt
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
die lauten 2 16 20 23 34 44 Superzahl 3
alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
der Mann singt und streitet fröhlich
weiter mit seinen wie er sagt lieb
gewordenen Feinden und kommt
gleichzeitig ins Museum Wolf Biermann
ein Lyriker und Liedermacher in
Deutschland das ist der ebenso
minimalistische wie treffende Titel viel
mehr muss man ja vielleicht doch gar
nicht sagen zu einem der in beiden
deutschen Staaten gelebt hat den die DDR
ausbürgerte und der auch im Westen
unbequem blieb und jetzt im Deutschen
Historischen Museum in Berlin bereits
als historische Gestalt im Mittelpunkt
steht Christa
die Rückkehr eines 86-jährigen nach
Berlin
Chausseestraße 131 1 die coolste Adresse
der Hauptstadt der DDR in der zweiten
Etage lebte Wolf Biermann seine Wohnung
war Treffpunkt für kritische Geister aus
aller Welt rund um die Uhr observiert
bis der Dichter vor fast 50 Jahren
ausgebürgert wurde jetzt ist der
zeitlebens unbeugsam freche dichte reif
für das Deutsche Historische Museum
es ist auch ein bisschen komisch
wenn man ein Museumsstück wird
und dummerweise noch lebt
doch wie würde ich man einen wie Wolf
Biermann der sich seit über 60 Jahren
einmischt Kommunisten so aus Hamburg in
den Osten ausgewandert dort verfilmt
verfolgt und verehrt wie kein anderer
ein deutscher Rebell der
Nachkriegsgeschichte geschrieben hat die
Berliner Ausstellung zeigt 281 Objekte
von der Abhörwanze bis zur berühmten
Konzertgitarre
im Mittelpunkt seine Künstlerwohnung in
der Chausseestraße dieses Bild ziert das
gleichnamige Plattencover
sie war da nicht mehr nur Wohnung
sondern sie war Aufnahmestudio sie war
Konzertraum sie war Treffpunkt für
Freunde sie war so ein bisschen was wie
ein Salon die Chausseestraße 131 wie sie
die Stasi fotografierte heimlich mit
nach Schlüssel und ohne Biermann 11
Jahre lang hatte der Dichter in der DDR
Berufsverbot bis ihnen die SED nach
seinem Kölner Konzert endgültig raus
warf Biermann wurde 1976 vertrieben der
gültige Mietvertrag nie gekündigt
könnten sie vorstellen hier wieder
einzuziehen
darf ich die Wahrheit sagen nein
ich lebe wunderbar in meiner Vaterstadt
Hamburg doch Biermann möchte seine alte
Berliner Wohnung zurück haben um sie
verfolgten Künstlern aus aller Welt
jeweils für ein Jahr zur Verfügung
stellen zu können
das war offen immer das Haus ist in
einem desolaten Zustand eine Biermann
Erinnerungstafel wurde zerstört für den
stimmgewaltigen Streiter ist die
aktuelle Demokratiekrise keine
Überraschung auch nicht der Höhenflug
der AFD Häuser und
Straßen und Brücken kann man in 30 40
Jahren wieder aufbauen im
Wirtschaftswunder nach dem Krieg gegen
das wunderbar schnell sie erinnern sich
aber Menschen gehen nicht so schnell
wieder heil das dauert leider Generation
und wer darüber enttäuscht ist ist
enttäuscht in falschem hoffen es wird
bloß aus unseren
Träumen
Biermann am Abend er träumt weiter sagt
was er denkt und eröffnet die
Ausstellung mit seinem Motto nur wer
sich ändert bleibt sich treu
[Musik]
Kopfgeld auf Kritiker wie weit reicht
der lange Arm Pekings unser new
york-horosponent hat sich auf die Suche
gemacht nach illegalen chinesischen
Polizeistationen auf amerikanischem
Boden und wir können alle gleich mit
dabei sein im auslandsjournal
und gegen 0:30 Uhr gibt's dann unser
heute journal Update mit Gundula Gause
von uns allen noch den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hinter den Kameras unangenehmer
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir sehen hier
Poly Poly ist ein außergewöhnlicher
Orkan in diesem Sommer denn er war sehr
sehr stark und zog allmählich weiter
nach Norden erreichte hier die
Nordseeküste und gefährdet hier noch die
nordfriesischen Inseln da kannst
durchaus noch Gewitter geben und dann
können durchaus Böden bis in der
Orkanstärke noch möglich sein wir
schauen auf die Nacht und da gibt's im
Norden noch teilweise kräftigen Regen
das zieht allmählich nordwärts mit dem
Orkan tief ab der Wind ist noch stark
lässt aber allmählich nach ganz im
Westen gibt's schon und ganz im Süden
sonst ist es trocken bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 7 Grad in der Eifel und
13 Grad z.B in Bayern morgen gibt's ganz
im Norden Schauer und der Wind kommt aus
westlichen Richtungen aber bei weitem
nicht mehr so stark wie heute ganz im
Süden einzelne Gewitter und die
Temperatur gleichen höchste Werte von 20
Grad an der Nordsee und 28 im Südwesten
aber wir erwarten in den nächsten Tagen
eine Hitzewelle Temperaturen steigen
dabei immer weiter an und erreichen im
Südwesten am Sonntag 37 Grad häufig
Temperaturen deutlich über der 30 Grad
Marke und 25 Grad an der Nordsee ja und
die nächsten Tage am Freitag relativ
ruhiges Wetter am Samstag kommen schon
erste Gewitter im Westen auf ja und am
Sonntag können diese Gewitter durchaus
schon heftiger ausfallen und damit einen
ruhigen Abend